بالفعل يعني عمليات البحث عن الجثث
والمفقودين تحت الانقاض تستمر في معظم
مناطق هاتاي حتى الساعه السادسه مساء
وتتوقف لليوم الذي يليه السادسه صباحا
تستانف ولكن هنالك مشكله كبيره الان هي
مشكله النزوح والعائلات التي بلا ماوى
وبالتالي نحن جئنا الى هذا المخيم الذي
اقيم بتبرعات من رجال اعمال اتراك ومن
غيرهم وانشئ هذا المخيم ليحوي العائلات
التي شردت طبعا هنا كما يظهر امامك تاتي
العائلات هنا تسجل تقدم طلب
لاخذ خيمه في هذا المخيم ولكن المشكله
الحقيقيه نايف ان عدد الخيام هنا
والقدره الاستيعابيه لهذا المخيم مثلا كما
غير قليله جدا وضئيله يعني هو بس فقط
يمكنه ان يستوعب 4000
خيمه وبالتالي 4000 عائله وهنالك اكبر من
هذا العدد بكبير بك طبعا هذه هذا المخيم
ليس فقط للاتراك وللاتراك وللسوريين وطبعا
انا ساسال عن هذه الاجراءات التي تتم
والتاخير وكل التفاصيل حينما اتحدث مع هذا
الشاب الذي جاء ليحصل على خيمه بعد اذنك
سريعا نايف صديقي اولا اتعرف عليك نبي
جدوع انت كنت سكان انطاكيا اصلا كنت وقت
الزلزال وين كنت بالبيت انهدم انهدم كم
عدد عائلتك ثلاث اولاد وانا مرتي انتو جيت
هون لتاخذ خيمه ايش عملت ايش الاجراءات
اللي عملتها بالضبط
متى امبارح وما توعدوك يعطوك خيمه يا
اليوم يا بكره
يا اليوم يا بكره طيب ممتاز انت بعد لو
افترضنا ان شاء الله انك تاخذ خيمه هون
لمتى رح تبقى هون في هذا المخيم ايش خطتك
هون تحرك هون بانطاك
كيف يعني ستعيش عمرك هون في المخيم حتى
الله يفرجها
يعني البيوت بره كلها غاليه ب 20 الف كيلو
وانت تسكن هون ولا
متطوعات طيب انت وعائلتك كم عددكم سته
ناويين تبقوا هون في المخيم وين تروح يعني
هلا تقطع اسطنبول بدهم 30,000 وتامين
بمارسيه نفس الشي عشرين الف انا
وانت ايضا سوري تقيم تركيا
هل تواصلت معك السلطات لتامين منزل مثلا
وعدوك بانهم راح يامنوا لك سكن بيت في
اخذوا علامه كتير يعني
العالم بتعيش وبتشرب ما في مصاري العالم
كلها راحت
انت وعائلتك كم عدد افراد الاسره كيف يعني
كم شخص كم شخص
ثمانيه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله سيكون كل
شيء على ما يرام يعني
هنالك شعور واحد بانه هنالك حاله من يعني
الضياع لدى الناس لا تعرف المستقبل اين
ستذهب بعد هذه المخيمات نايف وهذه مشكله
كبيره جدا لانه الاعداد تفوق القدرات
الاستيعابيه لهذه المخيمات طبعا مع
الاشاره بان هنالك مخيمات بسيطه او مساكن
او مقاول بسيطه يعني قيمه لذا استقبل كل
من يعني من ينام بالشارع او المرضى او ما
لديه حاله صحيه يعني يذهب اليها ولكن هذا
الحال لن يدوم طويلا ولا يصلح للعيش طويلا
لانه هذا مخيم وبالتالي الناس تعرف اجابه
واحده انهم سيبقون في هذه المخيمات لحين
ان تنتضح الصوره ربما من السلطات التركيه
او من غيرها يعني